welcome to this video playing DD this
must be my most frequent opponent really
and I have 21 games against him 16.5
score not bad almost eighty percent okay
we get an ouzo and probably the hoop no
variation check even without castling
yeah well this is not a huge difference
but given the choice I'd rather have not
cancelled it is some little bit more
flexible for black if you have not
cancelled in this close structures white
will play d 5 most of the time and now
expand yeah here castling is just
transposing through the the line that i
have in my upcoming book but i don't
want that I don't need to cancel here
but it's a it's a good in norman with a
4 hmm thats that's rare the whole idea i
mean is real interesting yeah i would
like to to play at five of course i
wonder if i should just play 98 nf5 very
straightforward yeah maybe it's no big
reason not to very interesting yeah but
is it a big problem the following be
seven oops sorry I don't think so b7 I
can always play would be eight maybe I
should have played age six first now
that I think of it he's got the the
night here 95 i mean this this could be
an issue
hmm yeah I kind of kind of forgot about
that idea but ok he ignored it just just
developed okay well I should I should
probably play this in any case make sure
you cannot you cannot play a 95 and this
is too seems very okay for me the
question is okay there is no question he
just took it if i should pay Bishop g4
maybe at at some point yeah the pawn
here hmm interesting how to play that
maybe I don't know the rook I can maybe
play a role on the fourth-ranked here
rook e8 i would like to sort of play
look at eight of seven I wonder if
Knight f6 is anything decent or is my
look getting into trouble it may be is
wrong maybe is
I don't know maybe look at four wasn't
nonsense idea I really need to my night
IAM the night cannot stay on the aid
forever yeah Knight f6 look evade
something like that need to get the
rooks connected I might have Queen c7
attacking the pawn it could be an idea
he does not really ok can play rugby
five maybe maybe that still still looks
a bit tricky if I'm rook be one I can
just take a 5 c 3 is also hanging I can
take a five a five rupees seven would be
seven Queens III is there a big
compensation for white I don't see it
can also take on c3 immediately but
probably not a good idea just do this
takes you three or look Queen a one
first this is an idea it should I night
be one maybe okay let's just take this
pot and see what what he what he shows
for it I don't really don't really see
anything
the night is a good protection to my
king and he does not have Queen F 3g 30
he needs to somehow get the Queen near
my king I don't see how this is going to
happen okay so let's let's use my main
trump card the a poll 94 I have Quincy
one check and queen f4 this is the end
of the night ii whole idea and you would
like to get the night over the border
okay it's probably preparing that Queen
D for maybe I could I could set up appt
in now with Quincy to now this is this
is also an idea open so night here I
have Queenie form or queen f what check
and then Queenie form I just need to
make sure that I don't get get made it
or get Jack gets that he gets some big
attack if this is not happening the a
poem will simply win the game and where
this is surprising the trade okay he's
going for a night f5 but this is so
dangerous you can take them now I just
push the ape on this is far too quick
check this is just the pawn is so just
promoting really
white resigns yeah he sort of ignored
this this c3 threat that this was also
also a problem around here I think I
should be comfortable in any case but
the pawn this whole idea with pushing
the a porn is it's a bit questionable I
think because long-term a5 is pretty
weak I mean you you cannot easily defend
this pawn with a minor piece man let
alone a poner this is always isolated
but it's it's a bit it's not clear if
this is really helping him very much he
prevents or makes it difficult for me to
have to play be six or something like
that but other than that I think it's
mostly weakness may be here he should
have should have played differently f5
was was very was very early and I
thought that well he took took and now I
played Bishop g5 I thought 95 would be
good here this really makes a six look
very weak I was thinking maybe night c7
now but this is not a move I love to
play yeah something something like this
you might go here that's a very good
position for wider I guess f5s is too
too early I mean I don't understand
stockfish evaluation you have plus two
this sounds very this sounds very high I
mean I understand that I'm under
pressure put bad plus two like I'm
totally lost sounds sounds like awful
awful high but maybe this is really the
case this is the the line that the
compass giving
I'm definitely worse definitely yeah at
five was Miss time yeah I should prepare
this with something age six maybe maybe
with age six something like this and
then f5 I can do that you cannot go
night h4 due to this tactic so um
probably this is better but he went
Bishop g5 and this is not giving me any
problems now maybe I should take on
these three this is maybe more precise I
mean not a big deal that the rukon f5 is
not terribly well placed this is al
Eminem I mean not not terribly bad but
it does not help very much as I figured
out that the crook is not good for F for
anyway ya hear I think I should be ok
but not better and I think he must play
rook a one here I don't really see what
else the figure was route b-52 come with
that I have this move and maybe he can
play something like that yeah that's
true yeah but we have from a comparable
situation to the game where I can snatch
the c3 porn this is better however in
comparison of course is much more active
yeah something along these lines I mean
this is just not working I think here
black should be a should be clearly
better yeah the computer grease minus
one point something getting higher yeah
I think it's hard to defend with the a
porn running down the board Quincy to
okay but this is also good yummy minus
two yeah it's this is too much the a
pawn it's just it's just too too
dangerous okay thanks for watching